then he went Donald Trump you know
Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no
more dropped by the drop boxes are just
so bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
whole logic and cephe Hyde
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth essential he voted against Kate's
law and he voted for Obama
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP Greg J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations than Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players
from suchin tendulker duviron Kohli as
the great religious teacher Swami Vive
[Music]
what said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
but it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
law and auto look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's ever seen
anything happen units of plasma for
plasma donate plasmid into failing New
York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous
gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business the teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while they're parent of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you heard them and you know them well
ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is really 2023 and for the
first time in history a president is
being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great use
such great news I was proven even more
right than I would have ever imagined
because apparently you know there is
actually igniting my father so great
orange leader maybe I was wrong maybe
prayer does work
great communist level of this is
[Music]
communist level this is
great communist level of
communist level of
great orange leader Dear God
forbid Donny boy God forbid Donnie boy
communist level this is
[Music]
communist level of
great to be here
[Music]
on
the people that don't know
[Music]
no do you like the fact that us has
liked more today no
no no
okay
seriously keep going
keep going
[Music]
seriously keep going what are you
talking about keep going what are you
talking about that's insane
thank you
[Music]
I think you're missing the pressure
you're not really doing this are you
all right welcome everybody a president
Donald Trump arriving now at the CNN
town hall now something weird seems to
be going on with this like a copyright
thing what was the way I'm supposed to
get around this I forgot what it is it
like only shows up sometime it's like
bizarrely shaped and
what was that issue that I how did I fix
it last time now I don't remember
someone told me that that is
extraordinarily annoying Dear God
um can any whoever was in the audience
can you remind me what it is I'm
supposed to do so that it uh picks it up
correctly
uh
we'll block the add blocker let's see if
that was the issue
see if one of my cyber guys was the
problem man I don't even know have
someone come forth a woman and spend two
days I know that wasn't it we have audio
what what it was such a simple fix from
the other day and now I don't even
remember what it was
anybody remember
I need to get a hold of one of pillows
guys I think there was it Hardware
acceleration was that it
I think that was it let me see if I can
fix that real quick
uh
uh where was that setting can somebody
just remind me where that is
so we can get this going yeah but where
do I turn off Hardware acceleration it's
not in stream Labs right I'm not doing
anything through Discord not doing
anything through Discord this is a new
thing with CNN this didn't used to
happen on CNN
Chrome settings Advanced okay let me
deal with that uh so we are going
settings and
Hardware acceleration we're going to
turn off
very good let's see I may have to
relaunch is the only thing we're gonna
get this working guys it's just you know
how there's there's Growing Pains I
think is the way we would say it and
then beautifully this evening okay so
Kristin let me just ask you if what he
does is what Hogan's doing which is make
I'm gonna have to relaunch that
I should actually check my 4 watt
setting I think that's actually the big
issue
uh Hardware accelerate relaunch here we
go
all right this is going to be the big
moment
here we go
extremely powerful moment here
for the stream which is really important
you know there we go and it feels like
and so what I'm going to be curious
about tonight and as we move forward is
how do Republicans react when Donald
Trump you know says the sorts of things
he's prone to say that get him into
trouble do they say this makes him risky
his legal troubles make him risky him
letting his mouth get the best of him
makes him risky and we can't risk
another four years of Joe Biden or do
they say all right everybody Welcome to
the program and thank you so much for
joining me this is an incredible day an
incredible day Donald Trump will be
given really it's a gift right will be
given a town hall event at Saint Anselm
in New Hampshire it is the 2024 election
it is happening now I want to remind
everybody as I already said many times
our YouTube rep
uh and our uh twitch contact I guess we
would call it both said if you stream
the event you're gonna get taken down
you may lose streaming privileges you
may get banned so we're this is like a
pre-show we're gonna go up until this
starts at the top of the hour and I'm
telling everybody right now then we're
gonna bail because we don't want to get
banned I want to be able to cover this
tomorrow Etc now let me address head on
apply directly to the forehead the
criticism that I know some of you are
going to make which is something like
that you shouldn't be covering this
because it's irresponsible it gives
Trump attention they're not going to be
tough on Trump and all of this stuff
I do a media criticism show
okay whether I talk about this event or
not it's happening Trump's running he's
the leader in the Republican nomination
all that stuff that follows fill in the
blank okay uh me not giving any critical
coverage of it is not going to do
anything for anybody okay I believe that
there is a chance that CNN is going to
do a completely irresponsible handling
of trump they're not going to go hard on
Insurrection they're not going to go
hard on indictment indicated they're not
going to go hard on the fact that he has
been found liable for sexual assault and
defamation against e Gene Carroll in
order to pay five million dollars
etc etc etc
so that is something that is the type of
thing I cover and so that's where we are
okay this may very well be an
irresponsible action by CNN we cover
irresponsible actions by media outlets
on the show
and therefore that's why we're talking
about so once again we will get blocked
from every platform if we stream the
actual event so we'll be with you until
the top of the hour let's hear what's on
people's minds let's see what people are
saying first of all Super Chat via
YouTube Tim Herbert sarcastically says
David sir three-time Nobel Peace Prize
winner George Santos was arrested today
I have so many tears in my eyes how
could they address such a man from the
party of Law and auto how terrible sir
yeah let me get my law and auto here
where is it law that's I filed that
under l
uh here it is if you care about Law and
Order let's actually talk about George
Anthony devolder Santos in a moment
first just real quick thanks to Joy kit
Howling Stars Susie ID
it's diondin
WTF irie man gouda Buddha diba Sam the
sleaze bag Pizza Man nasty questions
robot laser party your billion Jeremy
Ranch for the twitch Prime subscriptions
immediately bouncing us all the way to
14 also a huge thank you huge thank you
to Samuel he who just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com using the coupon
code indite there are three coupon codes
available to you today indict
indicted and indicated each offers a
slightly different discount indite
indicted and indicated and you can use
those at joinpakman.com let's look at a
completely unhinged
press conference for lack of a better
term that George and that the indicted
George Anthony devolder Santos held
after his court hearing now before we
even get to that see this guy in the
blue suit standing over George Anthony
devolder Santos's right right shoulder I
just want to make sure I get this guy's
name right
um
that is vishbura
vishbura has become a very interesting
player in the world of sort of New York
politics he's a completely amoral clown
really interesting long-form article
about him that I recently read I don't
have the details in front of me but
that's vishbura who has become sort of a
Clinger to George Santos and I think
sees maybe his political future he's a
Saul Goodman type character exactly
right Remora exactly right so that's the
guy in the blue suit but we're going to
focus on George Anthony here
um he says this is a Witch Hunt I mean
he's basically going with the Trump
Playbook let's listen
look this is the beginning of the
ability for me to address and defend
myself we have an indictment we have all
we have the information that the
government wants to come after me on and
I'm going to comply I've been comply
throughout this entire process I have no
desire not to comply at this point
they've been gracious in there now I'm
gonna have to go and fight to defend
myself the reality is is I'm sorry it's
a Witch Hunt because
they seem to have this guy dead to
rights on very serious crimes very the
the idea that he can get away with just
saying it's a Witch Hunt the way Trump
says
it's interesting that he's trying it I
think there's no chance in hell he gets
away with that sense that info four
months four months five months I'm
indicted you have Joe Biden's entire
family receiving
deposits from nine nine family members
this is like you know the fact that
other crimes exist alleged or real
doesn't excuse the fact that they've got
this guy 13 different charges folks
giving money from foreign from foreign
destinations into their bank accounts
it's been years of exposing a lot of you
here have reported on them and yet no
investigation is launched into them I'm
gonna fight I well and I'm just going
I'm getting back there I'm gonna fight
my battle I'm gonna deliver I'm gonna
fight the Witch and I'm gonna take care
of clearing my name and I look forward
to doing that okay I don't know that
that's necessarily going to happen here
he was asked if he will resign he says
no
I will not resign
a defiant George Anthony devolder Santos
will not resign
um here's more of the Witch Hunt stuff I
believe this is a different clip than
the one we just saw
to defend myself the reality is is
it's a Witch Hunt because
it makes no sense that in four months
four months five months I'm indicted you
have Joe Biden's entire family receiving
deposits from nine nine family members
receiving money from foreign all right
okay so we we saw that mostly already uh
this was a great question why would
George Anthony devolder Santos apply for
unemployment when he was making 120
Grand a year like somewhere he's lying
right let's listen in an orderly fashion
and we'll start right here
why would you apply for unemployment
benefits When you had a job making a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year Rachel this is part of my defense
part of his defense that's genius part
of my defense will be showing why I
collected unemployment benefits while
earning 10 grand a month in a job is
there accurate information what you have
to understand is I was lying about that
job to get elected I was really
unemployed that's why I was collecting
the unemployment I don't know that
that's the explanation by the way and I
will get to clear my name on this during
the pandemic it wasn't very clear I
don't understand where the government's
getting their information but I will
present myself
there's a sign that says de volder
defrauds devoters oh that is freaking
genius I just I wasn't even looking at
what was happening in the background
there is so much happening there's 80
microphones in front of the guy are are
some of those prop microphones just to
make it look even funnier devolder
defrauds devoters is great lies written
in Sharpie every detail of this is
stunningly done stunningly done
understand where the government's
getting their information but I will
present also has he been wearing this
exact same outfit since the day he was
sworn in
how is that acceptable ma'am like I said
my employment was changed during the
time I don't understand where the
government's coming from he's so very
confused it's all so confusing
um here he claims that he's soon going
to be chairman of a committee in a
couple years dude this guy's not getting
reelected this guy will be lucky to make
it one month
um Kevin McCarthy the Republican Senate
Majority Leader just announced he will
not be supporting the re-election of
George Santos now you might say who
cares it's up to the voters in his
district that's true when you when when
your party leader openly says I don't
want this guy reelected it's not a good
situation soon to be chairman listen to
this
standards of Congress look at the siding
there you go he'll be a chairman in a
couple years
um he's he was asked how he's feeling
and he says he's fine I guess please I'm
feeling look it's hard
I'm addressing I'm addressing one of
your colleagues here I don't want to
give the back of so
as usual Jody I I do my best to be a
positive person life is already as bad
as it gets his lips are moving so I I'm
fine you believe you're innocent I
believe I'm innocent he's totally fine
he stands by his total and complete
innocence
um
yeah
I mean these this is just unbelievable
that this is happening in Washington now
yes I am I have to go back and vote
tomorrow we have uh one of those
consequential votes in in this Congress
which is a border Bill and I'm very
lucky oh that's the he's pretending like
he's a normal Congress person it listen
Okay I mean fine I've been arrested and
charged with 13 different horribly
depraved crimes
many related to lies I've already told
to even get myself alive do you realize
I have to go and vote tomorrow we're
voting on the border Bill we're born but
we've got to deal with it forward to
being there
well I'm not going to address just the
speaker I'll address leadership I
appreciate everybody's patience with
with my presence in Congress as you know
the media has it's it's you know ways of
doing things and I'm I respect you guys
vishbura just bailed did you see that he
just left maintain good report with a
lot of you guys I've spoken with a lot
of you guys and I have the intention to
continuing that Open Door some of you
who are from the hill know how to find
me some of you here from the district
don't have a hard time finding me it's
about keeping in line all right so he's
asking for patience
um and here I guess he like held an
American flag as he left I don't know
his lawyer was asked about this and his
lawyer just seemed exasperated and was
like listen I that press conference that
was his thing I don't know he didn't
have too much that you wanted to share
at this time he just talked himself what
do you have to say about how your client
is feeling right now
it's looking for his car but hold on
with us Martha
I mean he had a lot to say in that press
conference but what's that something
okay I know you said you didn't want to
try it in the media but how is he
feeling he looked a little nervous when
he was in court today a lot of serious
allegations how many times have you been
arrested
you think it's a little nervous and
nerve-wracking so it's normal
it's normal Jitters it's the normal
jitters
uh anyone in his position would feel the
same way how confident are you that you
can prove that he is not that he is
innocent I'm not going to talk about the
case he's
right correct all right so not like the
most explosive uh
interview with the lawyer but the lawyer
seems more exasperated than anything
else quite frankly uh I want to say a
huge thank you to some really great
people who are supporting today via
twitch we we absolutely love it Cortina
deba chunky strudel Howling Stars lung
fleas Bevin Denson
jakori-isms Jeremy Ranch
your billion
uh that's six putting us at 21 and also
a big thank you to Charles pelons
Brendan Fitzpatrick and Helen freighter
each signing up at joinpakman.com if
you're just joining us Donald Trump will
be uh given the gift of a town hall on
CNN tonight in front of what I presume
will be mostly brown-nosing sycophants
of the highest order if you are
um if this is your first stream you know
we've had more than fifty thousand sixty
thousand new YouTube subscribers over
the last couple of months many of whom
many may not have seen a stream this is
a live stream and it is live right now
hence why we call it a live stream
unless you're watching a rerun of this
live stream in which case it is
pre-recorded
um one of the most important and
Powerful ways that you can support the
work we do is by signing up at
joinpakman.com it's an incredible
incredible thing we've got a website and
you click buttons and you sign up and
then your name pops up and then I thank
you and everybody cries that's uh really
really the amazing thing let's talk a
little bit about Joe Biden Hunter Biden
the right is now increasingly attached
to
uh wait I lost my clip where was this
clip it's the my Janine Pirro here it is
um the right is increasingly attached to
a story which alleges that Biden
received money I guess improperly from
someone foreign and as I've said before
I don't have the details they've been
making these allegations for gears at
this point I don't think anybody should
be protected I don't think anybody's
Above the Law if Hunter Biden committed
a crime if Joe Biden committed a crime
if Jill Biden committed a crime if you
know if Barack Obama committed a crime
Obama
investigate fairly charge if there's
evidence convict if a jury is convinced
right I don't want to Def I don't care
about these people as far as the cult of
personality is concerned that being said
I wouldn't exactly trust these people to
tell us what's going on Janine Pirro
lays out multiple lies in trying to
explain what's going on listen to this
this is how they do it what you've got
is the Hallmarks of corruption
the accounts the LLCs the evasion and
the money laundering the partners come
in collect the foreign money and then
distribute it to an LLC to an LLC in
incremental amounts Joe Biden is the
front man Hunter Biden is The Bag Man
okay Joe Biden goes into foreign
countries lecturing them about
anti-corruption and he is representing
the freest greatest nation on Earth and
is wrapping himself in the flag of the
United States while his son is
collecting the money at the back door
this happened in Romania and this
happened in the Ukraine
how are they still saying the Ukraine
how are they how is that still happening
he uses his position as the vice
president of the United States to tell
Ukraine to get the prosecutor off the
company where Hunter is a member in
making eighty thousand dollars a month
or he's going to withhold our taxpayer
money a million dollars a billion a
billion this is an appoint man in energy
and a point man on anti-corruption and
his son is right behind him with the
bags now let's talk they got George
Santos and I don't care about him one
way or the other in a couple of months
they got him on 13 charges Hunter Biden
five and a half years they can't figure
out how to get him on a criminal charge
this is a corrupt family it's the Biden
crime family yeah uh just about
everything she said there was a lie and
as decoding Fox News which is a great
Twitter account for those of you still
on Twitter and Twitter has become
totally totally disgusting
um Victor shoken was removed because is
the International Community wanted him
out because he wasn't investigating
corruption the amount was one billion
Janine Pirro said it was 1 million and
shoken was also not investigating Hunter
Biden so many many lies told there it's
it's maybe the most dishonest hundred
seconds of Fox News we've seen which
says a lot right which says a lot okay
let's look at some super chats Dominic
says sir any increased troll issues
after the strong Bannon mention no
nobody must be watching that Steve
Bannon show because he went after me on
I guess it was Monday I didn't get any
hate mail as a result of it which is
really really funny
the outbreak of Biden derangement
syndrome is putting Trump derangement
syndrome to shame they really are
deranged it's crazy it really is dexy
says how is something Biden supposedly
did as VP make him impeachable as
president years later thanks for all you
do that's only one of the hundred
problems with what they're saying
I mean it it's a it's a problem it's
only one
uh Britney says David since you can't
show the actual Town Hall could you
stream your reaction instead the problem
with streaming my reaction is that
everybody would be watching it on
slightly different timing it I tried it
once it really doesn't work so we're
going to be here until the town hall
starts CNN will be exerting extremely
powerful oppressive copyright uh
protection over the town hall our
YouTube rep said David don't stream this
because you're gonna get you're going to
lose streaming privileges you'll get
shut down twitch said don't do it
Facebook said nothing we have no
contacts at Facebook we never have it's
kind of a whole pathetic other story but
needless to say
um we will we'll be here till the top of
the hour then then I will cover it
tomorrow okay a big thank you to fire
timing really appreciate that twitch
Prime subscription super powerful twitch
Prime subscription also thanks to Jason
sickmeyer and Lisa Rader for the
memberships at joinpakman.com we have
three Trump related coupon codes
available today we have indict we have
indicted and we have indicated
pick the one you want and use it at
joinpakman.com it's an exciting day
David Can you steal that man the case
that Hunter's laptop was actually major
Biden's laptop yeah I mean listen the
perfect way to hide the crimes of the
Biden crime family would be to make the
dog the Fall Guy that would be the way
to do it so I actually think it's quite
plausible that what is being called
Hunter Biden's laptop is actually the
German Shepherd major Biden's laptop I
think that that's perfectly perfectly
reasonable
huge
huge thank you and shout out to S Prez
who just dumped in and I do mean dumped
in big massive dumps 50
subscriptions on Twitch 50 subscriptions
on Twitch s press Remains the top gifter
of all time on the Channel with 3 7 36
gifted memberships truly incredible
truly incredible all right let's look at
a couple of other uh things here
from uh from media
um oh wait a Michael Flynn Cameo this I
want to see what I'm known for is
standing up stepping up and speak
America and to basically fight for our
country and I I like to use the phrase
fight like a Flynn and I'm really
excited to to be joining and setting up
and launching my Cameo profile to offer
some personalized videos for anything
from a celebration of life a celebration
of a birthday an anniversary a wedding
he's glitching pretty badly it's
interesting I uh he charges 150. I only
charge like I think it's 40 bucks on
Cameo
um
I'm probably under pricing if he can get
150. that's pretty freaking compelling
stuff let's see Michael Flynn cameo some
people call it Cameo but that's that's a
story for a different day let's see uh
how many of these he's done so far
he has three reviews okay that's not
that much let's see how many reviews not
everybody leaves a review but let's see
how many reviews I've got I've got 158
reviews and I have a highly responsive
badge that's pretty good I charge 45
bucks okay I didn't remember what I
charge I I think I'm underselling myself
guys if uh if Flynn is able to charge
that much all right we looked at all of
the George Anthony devolder Santos Clips
already so I don't know that we need to
do that again
uh maybe we'll just go back over and get
to a few voicemails and a few different
things
great replacement yeah all right I'm
gonna get away I think we basically
covered most of what we wanted to there
as far as as far as that's concerned
um okay big thank you to Thomas Walsh
for signing up at joinpakman.com I do
appreciate that let's listen to a couple
of voicemails voicemails are just
pouring in
hi David Trump was found guilty of
sexually assaulting someone wrong he was
found civilly liable I do think it's
important actually let me ask that
people in the chat
is it important that we not say that
Trump was found guilty when it was not a
criminal trial and he was found liable
in a civil suit for me that's an
incredibly important distinction to make
particularly with sexual assault because
if you're found guilty of sexual assault
depending on state law you have to
register as a sex offender when you're
found civilly liable for sexual assault
the lawyers I spoke to said they're not
aware of any state in which you have to
register as a sex offender so it
actually seems like it's a pretty pretty
important distinction but needless to
say let's finish finish up the voicemail
essentially assaulting someone he
doesn't know and his defense is he
doesn't know the person he sexually
assaulted
yeah I mean I don't know that anybody
believes that at this point Trump
claiming I don't even know the woman
just doesn't doesn't make any sense
makes no sense whatsoever
um voicemail is also supporting in about
George uh George Anthony devolder Santos
hey David
um I was wondering why George Santos was
uh brought to Iceland is it because he
is a public official and it's no my
understanding and correct me if I'm
wrong in the chat if anybody knows I
believe that he was brought to Islip for
court because the FBI office
investigating him is based in Long
Island and thus that was the closest
Court uh can anybody correct and I
believe
I believe these are federal charges and
thus they can be uh brought in
at um
at any court maybe something along those
lines
sgtj says do you think Flynn went off
the deep end because of his age because
he had to be somewhat competent to be
promoted to General I really don't know
what happened
to Michael Flynn it's it's really
triggering though to a lot of people
because it is so bizarre
um here's a commentary on the town hall
that we are awaiting
hi Dave long time listener love your
show
Trump tonight I've stopped watching CNN
ever since they announced they were
going to host that with him
I'm curious to know what their ratings
are going to be like tonight and going
forward in the future
I don't think they're going to hold him
accountable
I think they're going to pose only
softball questions and so I accept all
the crimes he has committed
I was hoping you would cover it just so
I don't have to turn on the channel yeah
unfortunately CNN will shut us down if
we stream it so we'll go to later clock
and then we'll stop but here I actually
think there's a more likely scenario
I don't expect CNN
to not ask questions related to the
indictment the Insurrection the sexual
assault I think CNN will ask questions
or they will position audience members
to ask questions because remember it's a
town hall I think the questions will be
asked Trump won't answer them he'll
filibuster in the sort of free
association way that he does and there
won't be any serious follow-up that's my
prediction that's my prediction we'll
see it's I could be wrong I hope that
I'm wrong quite frankly
David sir are your cameo prices as
nearly illegal as your discount codes it
seems like it if Flynn is charging uh
150 you know
um okay voicemails continue to come in
hi David thank you that is an important
distinction to know that he's not guilty
and therefore there's a different
process and he doesn't have to register
as a sex offender right
um so what I was getting at when I was
saying that he
this is with someone he didn't know it's
not that he's lying about knowing the
person but that whether he knows the
person or not
what he did is bad oh Fair yeah no but
Trump's argument is
when Trump says I don't even know this
person of course you could rape someone
you don't know right I mean like my
understanding is that most rape is
happening actually with people that are
known to the to the offender
um but the fact that you don't know her
like you could just assault someone on
the street that you don't know it
doesn't prove anything Trump's argument
is I've never when he says I don't know
her he means I've never even been around
this woman I've never met her I've never
seen her
it's Trump's defense in that sense you
have to under understand Trump speak in
order to to sort of really get it
um more voicemails coming in about the
town hall
hey hello sir uh you know I think it's a
very important that we prepare for this
town hall by flushing our toilets 10
times 15 times because they're gonna be
big massive thumps of bull crap out of
his mouth tonight anyway that's all I'm
saying I very much agree with that very
very much agree with that I want to say
thank you to our friend from Tokyo Kyoko
awaya who just gifted three more
subscriptions also thanks to Bradley
Simmons for signing up at joinpakman.com
folks I have free memberships available
at davidpackman.com free membership now
I'm gonna say it again
it is singular not plural people write
to me after the stream they go David I
went to davidpackman.com free
memberships and then it said error
please give me the membership here's my
story of why I deserve a membership
it's singular
davidpackman.com free membership if you
email in the emails are ignored because
we don't do free memberships by email we
don't do them by smoke signal we don't
do them by Telegram
davidpackman.com free membership if you
want one of the free ones and actually
Kyoko from Tokyo just gifted one more so
uh that's that's all happening thanks
also to scuba steve Crimson Elric Bert
John old promp which I actually have
here president Donald J Trump
um and Dustin d as well that puts us at
88 and within Striking Distance of
today's goal uh okay a couple other uh
super chats here David would you
consider doing an internship program for
young people interested in the political
media world we used to do an internship
program the reason it's been canceled is
we're just too busy I have too much work
I've got a baby running around she
actually doesn't walk but it's
metaphorically running around
um we really just we just can't do it
it's um we're at the max and uh so the
internship program with peace and love
peace and love no more intern
applications pre please please because
we're totally full as far as that goes a
couple other voicemails here
let's see what um
what other thoughts
people have about the town hall
so David
you audience Donald Trump it stars I'm
concerned at this point is a convicted
offender well as far as you're concerned
doesn't mean that it's real
Trump has not been convicted
and therefore he is not a sex offender
okay and so I get it you consider him
he he's not though and if I start going
around saying Trump's a convicted sex
offender then I'm just lying to my lying
to my audience
hi David
um since Donald Trump has been found
liable for a sexual assault will he um
have to register as a sex offender no no
he will not see this this is many people
are asking this but it is not the case
it is not the case I can't do it I can't
lie to my audience we must be accurate
we must be precise we must be precise
um okay
let me see what else we have here Kyoko
awaya from Tokyo gifting three more free
memberships so make sure to grab those
at davidpackman.com free membership very
important those are available
um okay let's see just very briefly what
uh Newsmax is up to at this point in
time they are running
um
some kind of patriotic ads I guess is
NBC covering the pending Town Hall they
are not okay so if you're just joining
us uh Trump is getting a town hall
tonight in New Hampshire it will be
hosted by Caitlin Collins being a town
hall event the questions I believe will
mostly be asked by people in the
audience will there be quote tough
questions I think there will be initial
questions that sound tough and there
will be very little follow-up and Trump
will more or less get away with uh not
substantively addressing them people
saying David I thought CNN was cracking
down on people streaming their content
that's exactly right that's why we're
going to the top of the hour then the
stream will end everybody who wants to
can watch the town hall live I will then
be covering it tomorrow in a um
condensed way I guess is uh I guess is
the the way that we would describe it so
that's all happening and it is happening
very quickly and very powerfully and
very strongly I think it's going to be a
Nutty Nutty Nutty event that's my sense
right now
uh okay
a lot yeah a lot of lot of coverage on
Twitter of this
Carrie Lake on being labeled far right
let's see what this is about
and here's one they actually went after
uh one of my favorite people Congressman
Paul goes are one of the greatest
congressmen to walk the halls of
Congress in our radical extremist great
country Paul gosar to share stage with
members of Party founded by Nazis this
is insane stuff it's also true I'll get
to the last one here they called us
ultra-conservative you know what I've
been called worse here's one and this
one hits us Kerry Lake and Paul gosar to
appear with Far Right politicians you
know what I'll take that so far we have
been right about everything
yeah like for example that she won an
election that she actually lost truly
disgusting truly truly disgusting stuff
um
let's see what else we have here OJ
weighs in on the Trump trial that sounds
interesting uh in his deposition that
ended up uh leading to him uh losing uh
this particular verdict I also believe
and I gotta admit I do believe it's that
very
Hollywood Access tape is what's going to
work in here it's funny how OJ weighs in
on Trials merely because he was charged
with horrible crimes and convicted of
some so now he's like a legal expert
it's very interesting his favor in any
uh appeals that he does because I just
didn't seem that that should have been
lit in this case I'm a guy that believes
that you honor jury verdicts even when
you think they're wrong I am obviously
thought a civil case I had in California
uh was wrong it found him liable for the
death of his ex-wife I didn't think they
should have been able to have it
I uh totally disagree with the case uh
that criminal case I had here in Vegas
but hey
you know I I do believe you have to
respect a jury's verdict and I uh did
what I could uh all right I mean it's
it's funny because if you actually say
like what exactly are his credentials uh
uh it's that he's been charged with
crimes some of which he was found guilty
of really weird stuff in two years I'm
sorry yeah and then imagine a generation
from now that's what they want to do
here they want to make Texas a Democrat
State and you'll never see another
Republican in the white house after that
yeah I mean listen I think Democrats
want to make every state a Democrat
State Republicans want to make every
state a Republican state I thought they
had an app judge remember the act that
Biden unveiled that was going to make
everything orderly you just had to make
a reservation at the border and you'd
get right in apparently that broke and
then what about all these deals we kept
hearing that Joe was cutting with the
Mexicans I must there must have been
three or four Deals they said they cut I
don't think they ever had a deal and
what about the commitments Kamala had to
hunker down things in Guatemala also
that never existed
I was stuck behind a bus of illegal
immigrant families on my way to work
today in Midtown for about 20 minutes
whoa I would like to make a request to
Governor Abbott he needs to start
sending them
to Chicago
or Philly somewhere where I don't live
because now it's starting to really
affect me and I had to get out of my
town car and confront the bus driver I
said how long is this gonna take I was
speaking for the hundreds of cars that
were behind me you can't have this in
Midtown Manhattan wow really a man of
the people he got out of his chauffeured
of town car and uh whoops sorry about
that and uh he really he really uh gave
him a piece of his mind which is just
fascinating fascinating stuff I would
file that under when an entire jet blue
plane broke into tears because Eric
Trump boarded that's uh that that I
would I would say it's an equally
believable story Jacob asks will the
town hall only help Trump I don't know
you know it's we're going to analyze it
for what it is once we see it
um I don't know if it will help Trump or
not getting arrested seems to have
helped Trump
so
we're going to evaluate it thanks to
Bernie on a boat for the twitch Prime
subscription putting us at 92. if you're
just joining us I implore you to grab
yourself a membership at joinpakman.com
it is we actually proudly are primarily
uh viewer funded because of the
membership program and we do this insane
thing every single day called the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad all true
yeah we make money on the bonus show
Alex Jones as you just heard absolutely
hates hates hates hates it I think it's
a really great thing and uh if you use
the coupon code indicted or indicated
you'll get such an insane discount that
I can't say it out loud let's listen to
Juan who just left us a voicemail he
leaves a lot of voicemails I have to say
why do you think that Pharmaceuticals
don't want Medicare
to negotiate drug prices so that they
make more money
why do you think the FDA
approves so many medications well I mean
why does it approve it approves many
medications because they pass the
approval process I don't know
and what
influences the revision
well
number one
the pharmaceutical companies want to
push their medications
uh
so that people can obviously
manage their symptoms
and
nothing else can
help you resolve your issues your health
issues right what the FDA
members eventually end up working for
the pharmaceutical companies
and uh
okay listen this is a response to the
other day
um Carrie Lake said to
Piers Morgan
you can't even talk about big Pharma and
Piers Morgan was like
I can talk about whatever I want
and
um that was basically you know and I
said it is absolutely true
that big Pharma is for profit and wants
to make money and it's also true that
there has been tons of critical
reporting about big Pharma and so on and
so forth
um
I I just don't even really totally get
what the voicemail is about necessarily
but uh we we welcome every voicemail as
always thanks to easy3 James for the
twitch Prime subscription let's listen a
little bit to JP Mandel here is we're
trying to get the country back on track
I think that's what the president wants
to do and we should be very careful
about letting a political debate be
solved in the courts I don't think the
American people are going to fall on a
very very different issue before I let
you go Senator uh the rail safety bill
that you introduced with with some
Democrats as well uh it passed a big
hurdle today in the Senate that where is
it having tell our viewers why this is
so important to you well if you go back
to what happened in East Palestine that
terrible train crash we just want to
make things like this less likely and
force the railroad I really find JD
Vance just deplorable you know I read
his book hillbilly elegy and when when I
read the book it was well before he
launched this Senate campaign and
eventually became a senator and it was
sort of like okay I'm I'm guessing I
would lit I would disagree with this guy
uh on a lot of issues but he actually
seems sort of like a pretty okay guy and
relatively morally upstanding and so on
and so forth if there were only more
Republicans like him we'd be much better
off and then you know it went where it
went as you as you now know and I regret
everything I ever thought about JD Vance
to be totally Frank
super chats keep coming in Juan says
will Caitlin Collins be able to counter
the misogyny to be able to get any
hard-hitting questions and yeah you know
Trump often doesn't like tough questions
from female anchors and he sometimes
attacks them remember when he attacked
uh Megan Kelly during a primary debate
in 2016 and said uh what was it that he
said he said he said something like uh
she had she had blood coming out of her
wherever or something like that people
are telling me that our CNN's feed is is
a little behind I'll refresh it real
quick
and that should get us get us back we're
going to the top of the hour remember
CNN will not allow us to cover this so
we're not going to get ourselves in
trouble Ian with a 20 Australian dollar
Super Chat I appreciate that and big
thank you to Gene Fisher Gene just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
using the coupon code indicted which we
absolutely love a few other voicemails
coming in so I just wanted to know if I
gift a membership and like a gift a year
membership then do I get charged every
year for that gift membership no gifted
memberships you're only making a
one-time gift if you gift a monthly
membership that person whoever we give
it to because we have we have a list
they get one month and then they can
continue it themselves or bail and you
bail automatically I mean you don't have
to put in payment uh payment method if
you gift a year the recipient gets a
year and then that's it and then it's up
to them to continue so absolutely no
concerns no concerns uh as far as that
goes whatsoever if you're just joining
us we are nine minutes away from the
start of the Trump Town Hall in New
Hampshire I would love to stream the
entire thing CNN already told us through
our YouTube rep and our twitch rep don't
stream this we are we will shut you down
you will lose streaming privileges for
it's either 30 or 90 days I don't want
that to happen so we're going to go to
the top of the hour hour and then we
will
um cover cover this tomorrow let's
listen to a little bit of what's being
discussed here this other candidates
it's declared and Undeclared are going
to be coming through in the in a few
weeks right and meeting with voters
there so and you know people who are in
the room tonight who are detecting me
right now and they're texting you all
right so what are they saying uh the
saying is a lot of energy a lot of
excitement and uh you know listen he's
nothing but if not unpredictable and
that's part of the the fun of Donald
Trump or the power that unpredictability
and he is a fighter he's going to throw
punches and you can't kind of put them
in a box uh that being said I don't
disagree obviously with what we just
said it is going to be if he focuses on
Joe Biden and the economy in the border
and and Fentanyl and all the other
things we all know about the crime in
our cities that's they're still
mispronouncing fentanyl I I don't know
how they got to to call it fentanyl I I
have no idea I have no idea but many of
them do it thanks to James Daniels for
uh signing up at joinpakman.com your new
member number 95 today and I very very
much appreciate that let's listen to a
couple more voicemails as we wait here
uh for the start about for the start of
the Town Hall
uh let's see where we want to go to
yes Mr Pacman Roxanne Suarez again I
would like to know why it is called
Donald Trump versus United States of
America
because it's actually the United States
of America
after him suing him
it's the only place I've ever seen
something like that all right so Roxanne
making a very very powerful declaration
there
um the Eggman calling in
hey Dave what do you think generally is
more a sign of mental illness being born
in a body of a gender that you don't
identify with or believing a ghost
invisible man in the sky tells you what
to do and then you do everything that
man says
I actually liked Tulsi the second I
heard about her like years ago
you said stuff about her
I was a little doubtful a couple months
I figured out for myself she's a Russian
agent I did not even need Hillary
Clinton to tell me that but I figured it
out
why is being trans
considered mentally unwell but believing
in God is not that is insane to me
Shalom brother all right Shalom to the
Eggman who is just absolutely absolutely
shot out of a cannon people weighing in
on my interview uh three and a half
hours with Lex Friedman let's listen
hey David
um I like many of your listeners just
finished the Lex Friedman uh appearance
that you were on and I made it through
the entire three and a half four hour
episode and
uh it was it was a good episode it was
pretty unbearable through most of it um
mainly being because I'm not a fake Lex
Friedman uh fan I guess I
I just don't like the way he interviews
and and his uh
okay uh trailed off there yeah you know
what's interesting is if you look at the
comments on YouTube on Lex Friedman's
video with where he interviews me
um his viewers mostly hate me I mean the
ones who chose to comment mostly hate me
and then I got a lot of emails from my
viewers saying they don't really like
Lex Friedman
you know I I think it was worth I think
it was worth doing very much so
and you can't argue about every single
thing that's said you know you've gotta
kind of choose what you want to argue
about but uh yeah I appreciate all the
feedback here's a voicemail that just
popped in hi David this is Matt from
Indiana yeah I'm a teacher here in
Indiana and unfortunately the state is
uh
recently seems to be kind of going the
way of Florida and some other hard right
States so we passed our own version of
it don't say gay Bill we're talking
about arming teachers and I just wanted
to kind of point out uh you know it
seems funny we have all these bills
talking about how basically you can't
trust teachers to teach the children we
got to monitor everything they do we
have to monitor curriculum but then on
the other hand they're saying let's arm
the teachers and it's just kind of I've
made this point before let's give the
teachers we don't even trust enough to
pick books guns I mean it's crazy it's
crazy at its face but it's also crazy
for that stunning stunning uh contrast
that exists big thank you to Jacob
Burnside Matthew Curran and Lucy punawai
who just all signed up on my website
joinpakman.com all right folks we are
two minutes away from the start of the
Town Hall uh we will end our stream here
again CNN will shut us down for
copyright if we stream this I don't want
that to happen I want to keep being able
to post to YouTube and do do twitch live
streams so we're not going to cover the
town hall live we've been saying this
for days
let's all watch it together separately
um I'll cover it tomorrow on the podcast
and have a YouTube clip okay it's gonna
be Bonkers Bonkers Bonkers Bonkers and
we will see everybody very soon